[Music]
in today's eight on your side the nevada
department of motor vehicles has seen a
sharp increase in the number of stolen
vehicles recovered at its offices in las
vegas this past year
now the best way to avoid this from
happening to you is to bring the car
you're interested in buying to a dmv
inspection station
if you're wondering about a car you can
bring it into our vin inspection station
for free and no appointment needed
and we'll check it and check the
paperwork and see
whether everything lines up and
everything looks good we have some
pretty sophisticated
auto theft rings operating in the region
and the country
one trick they'll do is rent a car
and then turn around and sell it in
another state before the rental company
even
realizes what's happening or reports
it's stolen
here are some other warning signs and
important tips if the deal seems too
good to be true it probably is be
prepared to walk away without buying
now a private party seller must provide
a title
to the vehicle a bill of sale by itself
not acceptable
look at the title carefully for poor
print quality or other signs of forgery
and you also want to inspect that car
very closely folks for signs that it may
be a rental like he
mentioned or dealer inventory if it has
a small sticker or sign in the window
that's been removed
inspect the vehicle for flood damage as
well there's another website we want to
bring to your attention the national
insurance crime bureau very important it
offers a free
stolen and total loss vehicle check on
its website all you have to do is go to
nicd.org